mais tout d'abord l'inquiétude du côté
de l'Université de Besançon une
étudiante japonaise du Centre de
Linguistique appliqué a disparu cela
fait déjà 15 jours que ses amis et ses
profs sont sans nouvelles une enquête
vient d'être ouverte Emmanuel Rivalin de
Nicole la jeune étudiante japonaise
habitait ici sur ce campus de
l'Université de Besançon il y a trois
jours la police a forcer l'entrée de sa
chambre espérant trouver des indices le
début d'une explication sur le sceller
on peut dire la nature de l'intervention
enlèvement et séquestration une
hypothèse car la jeune femme de 21 ans
n'a pas donné signe de vie depuis
maintenant 15 jours
la jeune fille âgée de 21 ans habitait
dans l'une des résidences universitaires
du campus de la Bouloire elle était à
Besançon pour un an où elle devait
d'abord se perfectionner en français ou
c'est là le Centre de Linguistique
appliqué avant d'intégrer la faculté de
droit
[Musique]
la plupart des grands médias japonais
ont donc envoyé des équipes de
reportages à Besançon pour enquêter sur
la disparition de la gendarmerie
par cette affaire parce que c'était une
jeune fille de 21 ans pleine d'espoir et
qui était très contente de venir à
Besançon une ville tranquille sécurisée
[Musique]
les enquêteurs sont persuadés que Narumi
Kurosaki la jeune étudiante japonaise a
été assassiné le mois dernier a Besançon
la procureur de la République a expliqué
cet après-midi pourquoi la piste de l'ex
petit ami chilien de la jeune femme
était privilégié aujourd'hui par la
justice écouter
la famille de Narumi et ses proches
interrogé par les enquêteurs à des
rapidement évoqué la personnalité
envahissante et inquiétante de son
ancien petit ami d'origine chilienne
qu'elle avait connu au Japon et avec
lequel elle avait eu une relation qui
s'était achevée par une rupture les
policiers sont donc à la recherche de
cet homme un certain Nicolas un
ressortissant chilien présenté comme
l'ex petit ami de la jeune fille il
serait venu à Besançon début décembre il
aurait tué Narumi avant de dissimuler
son corps cet acte criminel était-il
prémédité en tout cas il aurait tout
fait pour brouiller les pistes avant de
regagner le Chili où il réside peut-être
encore
[Musique]
et j'ai aussi entendu des booms sur les
portes les meubles les cris il serait le
fruit de l'extase de Narumi que Nicolas
se qualifie de très réceptives
[Musique]
pour ceux qui en doutaient encore tous
les moyens sont engagés depuis un an
pour retrouver Narumi Kurosaki
les médecins légistes ont passé au
crible du tamis près de 20 tonnes de
déchets incinérés émanant des poubelles
de Besançon à la recherche de fragments
ou reste d'os humain
opération qui a duré un mois complet les
enquêteurs sont formelles la jeune
étudiante japonaise a bien été
assassinée mais le corps reste
introuvable d'où l'annonce aujourd'hui
de nouvelles recherches là où le
téléphone de son ravisseur à borné
pendant de longues minutes une zone
située au bord du Doubs près de Dole sur
les communes de Choisey et crissaient
[Musique]
les journalistes japonais attendaient
beaucoup de cette conférence de presse
deux ans après la disparition de Narumi
mais à peine arrivé le procureur de la
République annonce la fin des recherches
sur le terrain à ce jour aucun corps n'a
été retrouvé
on a cherché cherché chercher en fait ce
qu'on aurait souhaité avant de saisir
les autorités judiciaires chiliennes
c'est pouvoir démontrer que ces deux
jeunes femmes étaient décédées donc
d'avoir retrouvé ce corps dans ces
conditions l'affaire Narumi est-elle
éteinte pour la première fois le
procureur est revenu en détail sur
l'emploi du temps du principal suspect
Nicolas Zepeda l'ex petite amie de
Narumi ses déplacements autour de
Besançon quelques jours avant la
disparition de la jeune femme conforte
l'idée d'un meurtre prémédité
désormais plus rien ne peut donc
empêcher d'extradition de Nicolas Zepeda
vers la France la décision de la Cour
suprême du Chili a donné un grand coup
d'accélérateur à cette procédure qui
patine est depuis 4 ans au terme d'un
incroyable marathon judiciaire sur trois
continents
[Musique]
ce moment là cela fait des mois que les
enquêteurs Français l'attendent lorsque
Nicolas et péda arrive au palais c'est
pour y affronter le feu roulant des
questions du magistrat instructeur en
présence de son avocate venu
expressément de Paris près de 8h
d'interrogatoire plus tard la justice
reste sur sa fin je ne réponds pas aux
questions l'instruction est en cours
j'aimerais bon pas aux questions
l'instruction est
couverte par le secret il a répondu à
toutes les questions qui lui étaient
posées l'ivrante sa version des faits il
nie catégoriquement être impliquée de
quelques manières que ce soit dans la
mort de narimi Kurosaki et donc à fourni
des explications après voilà chacun
appréciera en fonction de
parquet et partie civils la défense la
véracité la crédibilité des explications
fournies par Monsieur Zepeda l'homme qui
a toujours confortablement joué sur son
terrain au Chili ne semble pas plus
déstabilisé en France son éternel aplomb
et sa rel de sérénité sont d'ailleurs au
cœur des expertises psychologiques et
psychiatriques en cours
[Musique]
il est près de 21h lorsque Nicolas
quitte le palais de justice il y aura
passé une journée marathon pas loin de
10h pendant lesquelles il aura versé
quelques larmes notamment lors de
l'audition de son père
Umberto puis de sa mère analys l'accusé
Louvois contourne remet presque le
président de la cour à sa place lorsque
la question l’embarrasse au Japon narroi
Nicolas fil est un parfait amour jusqu'à
ce que la jeune fille s'envole pour la
France et commence à s'émanciper la cour
épluche minutieusement les messages de
plus en plus menaçant que Nicolas et
péda adressent à l'étudiante elle
s'arrête sur cette vidéo postée en
septembre où il aimait des conditions
pour que leur relation se poursuive il
bloque son compte Facebook parce qu'elle
refuse de supprimer ses contacts
masculins en particulier Arthur
delpiccolo celui qui prend sa place dans
le cœur de Narumi
[Musique]